okay hey everyone it's Mike Vos here
from orderflows decom and this is the
orderflows market analysis for Wednesday
May 10 2017 the market showed a little
reaction to Trump's firing of uh FBI
director Comey really the big thing on
the data calendar yesterday or this
morning rather was the draw in weekly
inventories of crude oil oil uh jumped
up about a buck and a half to around the
4750 area also in uh the grains you had
the supply and demand report the month
of supply and demand report and there a
lot of movement in in the grains today
even though the you know sort of I say
the consensus but you know for a lot of
people the feeling of the supply and
demand report for a lot of the grains
was actually neutral but the markets
went berserk um you know and going all
over the place and I'll talk about the
beans I'm not going to talk about the
corn or wheat but um you know it was a
bit interesting you know it was the way
the grain move on the supply and demand
report you know just really reminds me
of of how snps and bonds
used to move back in the '90s early
2000s on the non-farm payrolls now it's
a little bit more subdued in the snps
and bonds but um you know the way the
grains were today you know just sort of
brought pack memories of uh a Time long
ago but uh before I jump in uh first go
through the uh brief disclaimer um you
know again I don't want people thinking
this is you know orderflow is some get
rich quick scheme in involving trading
it's not um you know it's or overflowed
teaches you to do is it teaches you to
understand the market you know
and watch the supply and demand forces
that are going on you know the reality
of trading you know what people are
risking in the market you know by taking
positions not necessarily just um you
know placing orders in the order book
above and below the the bids um you know
that's you know that is a form of order
flow trading on a dome is
but what we do with the footprint chart
is it's a little bit different it's
actual trades on people's actual
commitments in the market you know what
would you rather trade off is someone's
intention or someone's commitment to the
market you know would I you know
honestly you know if the Market's 67 and
it's going to be 67 yeah I would try to
sell at 8 knowing that the market 67 you
know I put big offers up there at 8 if
especially if I'm short at seven or if
I'm short at 6 and I could put offers up
there yeah that will influence the
market but you know unless you trade a
th at8 you know if it ticks up there
someone buys my thousand at 8 you know
that's going to change my perception of
the market you know I'd be committed to
a position and and i' have to work on
getting out of it so you know there
there are different types of orderflow
analysis you know one is Dome based one
is footprint chart based um you know you
people do make the argument that you
know on the footprint chart it's that
information is already passed you know
it's stale I I don't think so it's
recent and again it's shows people's
actual commitments to the market and
what would you rather do you know you
could sit here it's like dating right
you can say oh I want to ask that girl
out I want to ask that girl out and you
never do you know but when you're
trading you're in a trade it's going to
change your perception of what happens
so you know it's like you asked the girl
out now you got to take her out and show
her you know a fun time to have her you
know you're committed to that to that
date to that relationship if you want it
to grow whereas if you're just sitting
there you know in your head thinking I'm
going to ask her out you know then 5
months from now you know we're going to
be married and you know talking about
having kids but if you never do anything
it doesn't matter matter and you know
that's how I like to explain order flow
to people um with the volume footprint
chart you know it shows people's
commitment to the market you know once
you're in a position once someone's in a
position once someone's traded something
I think that has more uh relevancy than
someone's intention you know just
showing bids and offers above and below
the market so anyway a brief disclaimer
this presentation is for educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a Futures Contract or make any of
other type of investment decision
decision Futures Trading contains
substantial risk and it's not for every
investor an investor could potentially
lose all or more than the initial
investment risk capital is money that
could be lost without jeopardizing one's
Financial Security or lifestyle only
risk Capital should be used for trading
and only those with sufficient risk
Capital should consider trading past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results you know
people always say you know what's your
Edge in the market back testing well
yeah back testing is great on the data
that already happened um you know you
you can't trade on data that's already
happened you know where you're back
testing from you know data from last
year and six years ago you know markets
are constantly evolving things are
changing in the market and you know
people sometimes get really caught up in
past performance thinking that it's
indicative of future results that's why
you know the cfdc NFA you know they all
say past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results and results
for everybody's not going to be the same
you know my results doesn't mean they're
going to be your results you know I said
i' I've traded professionally for a very
long time you know when I say
professionally I don't mean you know
sitting in my my home office trading I
mean sitting in a bank trading you know
that's how I paid my bills that's how I
um you know paid my house paid my car
paid all that stuff that's what I did
for a living that's what I mean by
trading professionally you know you know
I see people saying oh I'm going to
become a professional Trader meaning
they're just going to become a retail
Trader you know there's a difference
there's a difference there um so anyway
the tools use in this presentation are
the orderflows trader and the delta
scalper
so you know First Market I'll I'll talk
about today is snps real quick um you
know S&P is in the morning very boring
morning again and you there was some
little bit of a movements that I think
could have been had and you know it was
in during the time of the room and I
just want to show you real quick this is
the four range
chart it happened around 9:00 so you
know in the morning we had been making
these highs you know just before 8:00
you got a high you got a Divergence it's
another high 830 right on the cash open
Divergence Delta scalper given a sell
here and you had the Stacked imbalance
but again you as to Stacked inbalance
you're going into the cash
open you do you want to take it you know
it's up to you you may have to hold it
up through the cash open and you know
things can really change once the cash
opens couple minutes past Cash open
again a Divergence so I already got
three divergences in about a half
hour and you know to me that's ready
that's a sign that you know we're
bumping up against the high hitting it
coming off hitting it coming off hitting
it coming off I start thinking in my
head you know we may be looking at a
market that wants to go higher I I would
say trending Market but you know the
last couple days have been kind of
boring but anyway um so I am kind of
looking for a move higher here so boom
boom boom fail divergences start coming
back up you got the Delta scalper given
this this buy here going into the high
then you hit this new high it's a new
high by a couple ticks so it's not a
powerful new high and you know you're
not seeing buying imbalances coming in
here you're not seeing people
aggressively buying so that's telling
you you know these if we hit this High
we could come off again before we make a
new high again it's not just oh you know
there's not aggressive buying that we're
going to hit the high come off into the
lows no we just it's just kind of
drifting around there you know at this
time you know our our range was 872
basically to 93 so you know basically
about a fivepoint range and you know
when you have a tight range coming into
the morning who's you got ask yourself
who's active it's not the big
institutional Traders cuz if they were
one you'd be seeing a lot more size
going through and two you'd see the
market moving and you know you don't
necessarily see a lot of size going
through in a lot of these bars the
volume and you don't really see the
market moving you know anytime you hit a
high or low of the day what you want to
see you want to see the longer term
Traders coming into the market you know
move the market away from value area to
find another value area and you're not
seeing that you know when you hit these
highs or even at these highs so you got
another Divergence up here Market starts
to come off okay you got no ratio but
you got ratio in the second bar 57 okay
which you know I talk about saying you
know even if you you have a Divergence
look for a ratio either in the bar with
the Divergence or the next bar okay you
get it but your move is going to be a
bit limited you're only talking about a
5o range at this
point it sells off um you know it sells
off from 91 3/4 down to basically 89 and
a quarter so yeah it had a little bit of
a move not the greatest move starts
coming back up now you're starting to
see some buying come in you know here
you had some selling imbalances that's
nice to see you know if you're short
then you start going sideways buying
starts coming in buying IM balance there
but you know three in here one in here
but you got ratio ratio
ratio this is the the setup that I talk
about the three in a row look for the
Red Bar in the fourth bar bar one bar
two bar three bar four pull back you get
the pull back to the point of control of
the third and second bar and you know
look for a move higher from there you
know and you start getting it you start
seeing some buying you know it just goes
goes up a little bit comes back down
boom comes back up buying and balance
buying and balance looks like okay
finally we're seeing some aggressive
buying come in and you know poos
possibly we could be taking out the
highs and we do um you know just after
10:00 we start taking out excuse me you
start taking out these highs putting in
new highs new highs you get another
Divergence that fails another Divergence
that fails start coming off um you just
going sideways in here start hanging in
and you know going you made the move my
my I ended my date at uh quarter after
1 or around there 1:30 but that's why I
got no data there but you know you can
see how the move was
and again you know sort of the first
sign early um you know everyone was in
the room not a lot of people but 10 or
so um today you know heard me saying you
know when you get these failed
divergences it's a sign and we had point
of control migrating higher as well for
the day you know those are early signs
that you know we could be moving higher
later and we do we get this we start
coming off but then you you get a buying
opportunity as well you know the three
in a row I mean you I don't want say you
got you could be you would be buying it
in here no but you know in here
definitely with the three in a row this
pull back down to the 91 and 3/4 area 92
you know then a move all the way up to
95 you know that's that's a decent move
on you know how it was you know
especially on these days in the snps
that are doing um basically
nothing so you know that that was it you
know the 5
years today you know the bonds in 5
years again you know sort of did nothing
most of the morning 5 years very boring
there was activity uh later around uh
around 12 but um I just want to show you
you know something that again another
thing I talked about in the room this
morning where was it here you know it
was taking forever to form These Bars
you know this bar is about 809 at then
910 so another 1 hour to form this bar
another 35 minutes to get this bar but
you know this is what I I was
highlighting this in the room today you
had point of control point point of
control point of control two at the same
level one to tick higher and really what
you know even though you had a Delta
scalper there okay you
know I'm not going to deny that but
um you have these points of controls
when I see point of controls lining up
at around the same level to me that's a
market generated level a support level
or resistance level in this case it's
resistance level this last bar is down
we're trading below it Point next bar
point of control below it so it's
telling me you know I Market looks more
like it's going to sell off than rally
you know even though you have the Delta
scalper here um you couldn't rally past
you know the previous high of this bar
so that's you know to me that's telling
me that's not U going to be a good trade
you know I said I'm looking in this bar
you know if you just go here like
this and you know think hey I Del
scalper I got to buy and you buy and
then you look at this bar
really it's not encouraging because one
you can't get past the previous High
can't you you only get one tick past the
high of this bar with the delta scalper
in it it's you know if you're looking if
you're along you don't get married to
this trade you got to get out um you
know it's it's easy to say that after
the fact but you know really you got to
real you got to you know people get
sometimes get married to trades and
forget to read the order flow as it's
happening but you know if
you're you know I said you're at this
point right you these point of controls
in this area at 1 and a half 1 and 3/4
then the next bar point of control same
level but the bar is down know that's
that's not a good sign that's definitely
not a good sign so you know you have
this resistance level up here and you're
trading below it you know and if you're
long and you're trading below a
resistance level that's not the best
trade then especially the next bar
starts trading lower point of control
lower as well you know said if you're
along this Delta scalper you should have
been out already but definitely by this
time you should definitely be out
but really you know this was key to me
um you know reading the market the point
of control is you see how it's it's
lower you get short you know I say get
short but you know it it has going to
give me more of an opportunity on the
short side than on the on the long side
and you know we start trending lower
over the next hour or so um going down
into the lows you know 12:00 you had
some stuff coming out but um you know
that was that was it this was the key
here in the five years this morning
now the next Market uh where is it
here crude really
quick so anyway you had the inventory
numbers come out you see how the market
is going berserko there uh there was
something here okay so there's a couple
of things this point of control 945
point of control right at the top which
with the ratio which is bearish you know
it came back it said it made new highs
um you know went higher so you know this
one I'll be honest you know you know I
want to show you times where trades fail
um you know not every thing is going to
work out picture perfect you know you
had a high point control at the top you
got a ratio look to get short it doesn't
happen um it just rallies back up there
and makes new highs now you get up here
to this High you don't have a ratio what
you got here is this Delta scal we given
a cell and you got a huge negative Delta
strong negative Delta minus
2, 340 which you know for an eight range
crude oil chart that's pretty massive
actually
and you know it's right off the high so
you hit your high right after it you got
a huge selling coming in you got some
supportive buying 1 1300 12200 see about
2 and a half thousand bid here on the
bid that got sold into and you know
there's no more support there and you
just see how the floodgates you know
just it just sells off right there it
gets down into this area you see some
support coming in down here um does
rally back a bit
later get up into these uh High areas up
in
here and you know just sort of going
sideways you lower point of controls you
know Delta scalper given a buy there
with the ratio into some new highs a
sell sorry this was the Delta surge sell
with the scalper buy with the scalper
back um you before we start uh coming
off here hitting this new high area and
sell off again poter control here is at
the top you get a little bit of a move
lower um you know not not the strongest
move but you know move about 15 cent
move you know so this one worked out the
one earlier in in here didn't you what
time was that that was around
9:45 you know here this point of control
at the top it didn't work out later it
did later gave you a nice little
move so again you know I I don't want
people thinking you know every single
Buy cells can be predicted with order
flow no I mean you still got to read the
market uh
eurocurrency really quick
um just go back to around 7:30 time
again you know point of control right at
the top of this bar you know it's a
swing high you can see how you know no
previous high before Point control right
at the top you got a ratio you got the
Delta scalper you got you know I'll say
a
trifecta you know people say well if I
combine this with this with this you
know it's going to be better yeah
probably I'm not a big fan of you know
the star system what I call the star
system you know U you know I really used
to be involved in horse racing in my
younger days and you know one of my my
best friends he would get the racing
form he put check mark you know Star
Circle this that on on the form I me
looking at his Racing Form he's got all
these squiggly marks you know and I'm
like well which one do you bet well the
one with the most squiggly marks is the
one that he would bet um you know got
love them but uh you know yeah you can
make the argument of Confluence you know
where you get a lot of things going off
at the same time but you know each one
of these you know either the delta
scalper or the point of control or this
ratio you know would be actionable but
yeah is it better to get a few probably
you know honestly yeah you know I do
like getting point of control with the
ratio I do like getting Delta scalper um
you know actually by itself but you know
so here you don't get you get a little
bit a move off this area just but it
just goes sideways unfortunately for
about you know 45 minutes before it it
starts selling off you know down into
here where you get this now this low
here the swing low is a little bit
interesting you had a dogee bar with the
Delta scalper then you get a bar here
point of control towards the bottom not
a ratio but then the next bar you get
the Delta scalper again get a nice
little move up comes back down tests
this low area where the point of control
was down there um Delta surge here on
this move up Delta scalper given the
sell down here again Delta surge a
little pop
up price rejector given a buy here so
you know depending on your type of
trading you know if you're very
shortterm long term I don't know um you
know that there's little bit these
little moves to be had and then you know
later in the day you got this you you
come back up here to the swing High got
a ratio up here 83 which is bearish okay
you had a ratio here but this one you
know it's just a double top and it's a
little bit more volume again you get
unfinished business for un business
Fanatics out there look for the market
to come back to that area so you know be
careful about getting short off this
ratio we do come back up here make this
new high single print then you get the
Delta scalper here and you also you got
the transition this this if you could
see that that yellow and this was a nice
sell you know from the 90 area 88 89
area down downtown downtown down into
the 70s um so you know there was some
decent uh honestly there there were some
decent moves today you know it's just
you know recently though the S&P during
the mornings have
been for lack of better word uh
uneventful but you know some of these
other markets oh okay talk about the
soybeans really quick because I had
alluded to
that um I alluded to that market earlier
actually so I do want to get the chart
up for you if I could just find it
here you beans beans
I CU I say you know the way it was
moving today after the USDA report
really is reminiscent of uh how s smps
really used to move so again you know
point of control this is a 8:30 you know
point of control near the top of the bar
didn't work out you know ratio
Divergence you know you got a few things
sold off you know it's 834 so it's
within the first 5 minutes of the
reopen and and I know that you know alos
that off on the on the
open you know at 8:30 you know give them
you know I know people that run them I
know Traders you know at Banks I don't
want to say what company of JP Morgan or
whatnot but you know I do know the guys
on the execution desk and how they would
enter these
orders and you know they get orders on
the order book you know that's you know
starting at the at the 8:30 open you
know vwap you know just start buying or
just start selling and it usually lasts
you know they put it in for 5 minutes
you know either they do vwap or they do
percentage of volume and it will usually
last for about 5 minutes depending on
the size of the order um you know
they'll do it for about five minutes or
so that's why I like to give people ask
why do you give five minutes that's
why but anyway you know this one didn't
work now here you got a Divergence at
the high of the day and you know do come
off a little bit start coming up now you
get this bar here very strong Delta plus
783 you got a ratio you got stack buying
and balance you got the delta scalper
then in the next bar you got a bearish
ratio you got three a single print there
and can you know when you have this
stacked imbalance you know what you want
to see you want to see continued buying
you don't want to see selling come in in
price rejection and when you do it's got
a high percentage chance of failing and
it does it comes down in here it goes
sideways sideways sideways now it's you
know this time it's
10:00 you know 9 11 is is when the
report comes out so you know keep you
got keep that in the back of your head
but really you know when you have a
stacked in Balance look for the move in
the next two bars if it's not happening
in the next two bars if you're still in
it by the third bar it's probably not
going to happen it's probably not going
to be very effective when I say it's not
going to happen what I mean is over the
next five bars again I don't look as
being a level all day long I'm looking
at it being a level for the immediate
term because you have aggressive buying
coming in here what you want to see is
when you pull back in there you want to
see the aggressive buying come back in
instead you're seeing aggressive selling
which is not necessarily the what you
want to be seeing so anyway and it t it
spins its wheel for an hour um basically
just around that area so you know at
best you would have maybe lost a couple
ticks on this trade you know if you had
traded this or you know I said I say it
lost but you know at best you would have
broke even I don't think there was no
capacity to make money on that trade
started coming off um you know we're
coming into the 11:00 time you come up
to the high make a new high you got a
Divergence nothing um 11:00 and the
market Market you just see it's all
zeros on the bid side just all buying
it's just all reactionary buying you
know you're you're not going to be
trading here realistically you know
11 o and you know 06 07 07 07 08 yeah
you could I could make the argument that
989 there is resistance you know you can
see the buying and balance up there 171
236 but against four against 230 zero
against 171 so there is offers up there
there is offers you do have you know buy
and balances you've got ratios ratio
bonds lows you got um you don't have
divergences but you know you've got a
lot of things you know kind of negative
but honestly the way the Market's moving
most people wouldn't be trading it now
you know then we come off again it's
coming off within 20 you know we we we
made a move okay so what I'm talking
about you made a move you went from 979
all the way up to 980 989 back down to
970 you know 981 um 979 and this is
within 20 seconds of the number coming
out not a lot of volume going through
you can see you know 40s you know 18s
sixes um you know Delta scop are given
to sell here again I you know if you
automated your system you would have
caught that um you know going lower you
know it's just going all over the place
here boom boom boom and then you know
Delta scop we given another sell here
you know right into the low you know am
I going to say at this point it slowed
down a little bit well it took about 20
seconds for this bar to form another 20
seconds it's taken about 20 seconds now
as where as before it was taking 2
seconds for a bar to form um picks up
sells off into these
lows um you know hits this low got a
Divergence no ratio rallies bounces up a
bit comes up here Delta scalper given
another sell this time it just goes
sideways you know you do have a ratio
and price rejector as
well doesn't do anything it just goes
sideways on you um got Delta scalper by
Delta up or sell here right into these
um you know I'll say right into the lows
came down bounced up a little bit hit a
new low point of control right at the
bottom with a ratio which is to me is
bullish didn't work
out hits this low starts bouncing up
hits the low again no reason to buy here
no reason to buy
here and you just sort of going around
hit the low again come down here boom
hit the low point of control right at
the bottom again it's 110 Market's
closing in 5
minutes uh bullish sorry bearish ratio
you you do rally up going into the close
so yeah honestly I feel exhausted just
talking about that market you know just
you know how crazy it was now you know
people say well can you trade that yeah
you can um you know I I used to I used I
used to trade snps when it was on the
original Globex system during the
numbers you know I used to trade at
night I would come into the office at
around 10:00 in the evening and I would
leave
&ps on the original Globex closed at
8:15 and then the floor opened at 8:30
but you know and those numbers were back
in those days you know it was the big
S&P where it was was like 25 25 bucks a
tick and you know really you get you
know a full point move you know and that
was when S&P was trading uh you know 550
so 550 to 551 and it was moving in
nickels you know that's a $250
hey is that
right I can't remember now but you know
it was the big snps back then but big
S&P wasn't as as big a contract as it is
now because obviously they come out with
the minis and a lot of people are
trading The Minis
but what you want to do okay I'll give
you
Mike's big number trading method you
know when you got a big number coming
out really the supply and demand number
for the snps is like the FED
announcement the non-farm payrolls all
put in together rolled into one and and
what you want to do is anytime you hit a
high or a low look for a reason is there
a reason to buy or sell now you're not
going to get it you you're usually not
going to get a reason to stay in the
trade very long so it's just it's just
what you're looking to do is just get in
as fast as you can get out as fast as
you can for um what you can out of it so
you're coming up here again you got to
be very fast I I don't recommend this
for most people and you know if you're
doing it you should be in an arcade
where you got you know the server direct
line to the CME or your your latency is
is basically zero and again you know
most people if you're sitting at home
forget about it you can't and you got to
be very fast so you're coming up here
you're hitting these highs one two three
times you see there's volume up there
you should be looking to sell but you
know if you're sitting at home you see
this if you're even if you're very fast
by the time you hit you sell it at the
market don't try to work bids or offers
you got to sell it you got you're going
to get screwed sometimes because you're
going to get lousy fills you know you're
just looking to sell it you just hit
whatever bid you can and you know you're
trying to sell it if you're trying to
sell it up here at the market probably
getting filled you know down here at you
know two or three cents off of where you
wanted to sell it but again you know the
Market's got a lot of volatility so you
got to you know then quickly again you
know this goes back to the original
globic system you know so as soon as you
get your fill back you got to think
about where you're looking to buy and
you're just you know so you're selling
it you want to sell it you're not going
to sell it up here you're not uh to be
honest and you you're selling down here
985 okay maybe I get 2 cents out of this
move three cents you know so you you're
thrown in a bid here then by the time
you get it in you're filled and you know
you put in a 983 bid by the time it hits
the market you know you're filled
probably a little bit better 981 and a
half and you're probably thinking oh I
should have waited a little bit longer
but you know what it could move on you
really quick and then when you get down
into the lows of the day I mean really
you be looking for areas to trade around
you look at this low is there a reason
to buy here well yeah you have a
Divergence maybe you're interested in
divergences you're willing to take a
shot not me um you know I'd be looking
for something else like like here I'd be
looking here I'd see well there's a
point of control at the bottom there's a
ratio I like yeah I'll try and buy it
time I get in you know I'm filled up
here I got to have my stop you got to
have a stop in on days like this either
that or super fast reaction time to get
out you get out very quick look for no
other reason to buy nothing down here
nothing down here down here yeah you do
have a ratio but that's it you know I'd
like a little something else here you
get the Divergence it's coming into the
close though so you got to be in and out
very quick get what you can out of it
and you know it takes about it takes
takes you know it's very close whether
you you'd be even taking this trade you
know by the time you're getting in
you're closing in about 2 minutes so
it's just in and out very fast so you
know really how I would trade those in
the past you know you just look for
these areas where you're hitting the
high or lows and if there's a reason to
sell
there um you know yeah you can make the
arent I just want to catch the move you
know you move from 989 down to 966 I
just want to catch two cents in there
yeah you can probably but you also might
catch you know three cents of heat which
you know for some people is going to be
unbearable by the time you you cut it
then the market is back in your
favor so again you know that that's not
something that's recommended for people
now I I see a lot of um I don't say new
be Traders but you know beginning
Traders you know they'll post charts you
know oh yeah you know I had this great
day you know on their Sim account you
know they're
trading in there um you know saying oh
see the system would have said buy here
and sell there but you know
realistically going back up
here you I'll be the first person to say
yeah you know there was some selling
signs up here but you're not going to be
selling it up here you're not going to
be selling it you know if you could sell
it above 985 that's a tremendously great
fill but realistically you're going to
be getting fill down here 981 982 that's
really the most realistic fills you're
going to get and you know then if the
market sells off and starts coming back
up and you know say okay say you got an
offer down here at uh you know 987 we
sell off down to 980 you know 980 977
start and imagine if we start coming
back all the way up to 987 chances are
it's going to keep going higher you
don't want to be shorted up there
anymore you know I mean that's what what
people people lose lose sight of you
know on a volatile Market but um you
that's why I laugh when I see people you
know put sort of these these things and
post these uh charts online now lastly
this is the U-turn this is one of the
Volos indicators Volos U-turn I call
these things after myself because you
know people have been stealing my ideas
at least you know I don't mind stealing
my ideas just give me some credit for it
you know that's all that's why I Nam
these things S&P sorry mini dog gave a
nice a nice buy here right on this this
this low and you know it's a move from
um you know what was that 870 all the
way up to
930 a little bit later gave this one but
it sort of puked out on you um anyway
you know not to be uh not to be uh out
shown is the transition which for me is
usually a pretty good
indicator right after the cash open gave
a sell here this one stopped you out
this one went nowhere before it jumped
higher on you didn't work out and you
got the sell up in here you know which
is going down into right around uh well
1:00 is I said you I turned off my
system went down about uh just after you
know
1:00 gave some false buys here this
first one didn't work out second one no
reason to take cuz he didn't go any
higher but this one you know it just
sort of went sideways on you so you know
there was there was a couple of Trades
here you know that I say a couple that
worked out one you know it was about to
break even day on that transition but
anyway you know the the Delta scalper
you I've been showing you guys a lot
that I've been having a lot of interest
from people asking me questions about
that Delta scalper indicator which you
know on your currency has been doing
fantastic recently and you know to learn
more about it uh go to Deltas scaler.com
or to learn more about orderflow in
general go to my website order flows.com
and be sure to subscribe to my YouTube
channel so whenever I post a new video
you will uh be notified for it so thanks
and bye-bye